deep beneath the thick layer of
million-year-old ice something is
lurking quietly waiting to rip through
the rigid ice sheets no not that this
enormous icy wasteland is sitting on top
of a volcanic Ridge and in our
hypothetical world these volcanoes are
about to wake up could their scorching
lava wipe out the surface of earth or
would the thick Antarctic ice stop the
lava before it makes our planet
uninhabitable this is what if and here's
what would happen if Antarctica's
dormant volcanoes woke up
Antarctica is the coldest continent on
earth and it's quite mysterious we
didn't know it had active volcanoes
buried underneath it until 2013 when
scientists accidentally detected two
clusters of small earthquakes
now that we've scanned Antarctica with
ice-penetrating radar we know that there
are many more volcanoes hiding below the
ice 138 to be precise but that's only
the ones we know of how many more could
be hibernating there and how much
trouble would we be in if all those
volcanoes suddenly decided their slumber
was over it shouldn't be too surprising
that these Ash breathing ruptures have
been buried underneath
Antarctica's ice shield this whole time
after all
volcanoes are easy to come by even
outside our home planet there are
volcanoes on Jupiter's moon Io Saturn's
moon Enceladus and on our planetary
neighbor Venus but let's not waste our
time there we've got our own world to
save do you know what happens when a
volcano erupts
there are usually warning signs before
the real action begins like the waves of
earthquakes they indicate that there's
molten rock moving beneath the surface
then lava and ash join the party
accompanied by heated gases it depends
on a variety of scenarios and the kind
of lava involved but on average lava
moves at about 10 km/h pretty easy to
outrun but when a major eruption occurs
a volcano releases superheated gases and
ash combined they create something
called a pyroclastic cloud these things
are hot reaching up to 700 degrees and
they can move at 80 km/h being trapped
by one of these would mean the end of
days for you but and arcticus volcanoes
are a different story they're buried
under layers of ice that are more than
four kilometres thick in places we
wouldn't be dealing with volcanic gasses
making their way to the surface at least
as far as one eruption goes the heat
released would melt massive caverns in
the ice creating substantial amounts of
meltwater and that's when things would
start getting ugly the newly created
meltwater would cause the ice above it
to move more rapidly the Antarctic ice
cover would begin heading into the ocean
from there the domino effect would kick
in
the huge weight of the ice puts all that
pressure on volcanoes keeping them
stable but decrease that pressure and a
volcano gets limbered up and magma finds
a way out through an eruption in the
case of Antarctica multiple volcanic
eruptions could wake up over a hundred
other volcanoes and destabilize the
entire region as the volcanoes continued
to blow their tops more meltwater would
be created causing more of the Antarctic
ice to slide into the ocean Antarctic
ice would be enclosed by warmer ocean
currents on one hand we'd get a new look
at Antarctic bedrock that's been hiding
under the ice this whole time on the
other hand the ice wouldn't just
disappear into thin air it would melt
and if all of Antarctica's ice melted it
would raise the global sea level by
about 60 meters rising sea levels could
contribute to major storms moving slower
and dropping more rain hurricanes and
typhoons would wreak havoc on the
Earth's surface wildlife along coastal
areas would lose their habitats and
agricultural soil would become
contaminated with salt extensive
flooding would push millions of people
away from the coastline
if the eruptions happened in the span of
one day we'd be looking at thousands of
deaths and storms wiping out everything
floating in the oceans but let's go back
to Antarctica for a second now that all
the ice has melted what about the
rampaging magma
the good news is it wouldn't turn the
earth into a lava world after all the
eruptions would occur under water the
hot magma would solidify in the cold
water of the Antarctic Ocean and maybe
add more real estate to Antarctica zone
bedrock but things don't end there when
volcanoes erupt on land they spew out
heated gases including carbon monoxide
methane carbon dioxide and nitrogen to
go along with this there's usually some
water vapor thrown into the mix by some
estimates volcanoes are responsible for
the release of 645 million tons of
carbon dioxide every year if the
antarctic volcano eruptions turned out
to be powerful enough they would blow
open huge expanses of ice allowing the
release of even more toxic greenhouse
gases when one of Antarctica's surface
volcanoes mount to chi erupted some
18,000 years ago it spewed out the
chemicals that ate a hole in the ozone
layer that hole warmed up the southern
hemisphere and caused glaciers to melt
it helped wrap up the last ice age now
imagine over 100 volcanoes erupting all
at once that can't be good for our
planet but don't worry
Antarctica's volcanoes won't erupt all
at once if they start to wake up it
would take decades for anything
substantial to happen me I still think
we should be ready for anything even
adapting to living under water when sea
levels rise but that's a stir
for another what if
you